all right guys
bang bang i have a very special treat
for you today christian is here thank
you so much for doing this sir
welcome um super happy to be on the
vodka super excited
so yeah absolutely absolutely let's just
jump right into your background there's
a lot of people who probably know some
of the work that you've done
but don't necessarily know your entire
story so where did you grow up and kind
of how did you get into business and
investing
well broad question so um i grew up in
germany to be precise actually in
bavaria which maybe some of you know
from
oktoberfest uh she's always very funny
because i never drank alcohol
so far so although alcohol is like the
bavarian like
basic nutrition so so and you've never
drank any you've never drank any alcohol
no i don't why um
super long story i tried i mean when i
grew up in bavaria like i
i grew up in this super tiny village
like till till i was nine it was like 90
people and then we moved to a
town which was 2 000 people so it was
very
sheltered and i always already early
realized that i had two
things which uh sort of were very
special
which what was happy about it i was
always a very happy child
and i was also always very good in
school so
and i i was really afraid of losing that
so i was like ah if i put something in
my brain like alcohol
then um then maybe i'm losing that sort
of
perfect equilibrium so so i decided not
to touch it and then it was a
stupid bet so it was really like like we
were like 13 years old i was like i'm
never going to drink alcohol and then
all my friends were like you're not
going to make that not in bavaria and
then it became
a bet that i'm not drinking alcohol till
i'm 18. so if the whole school was
watching
yeah then and then it sort of stayed
that way once you're not drinking you're
a designated driver
and then i really think it's really bad
so i know it's like
i always spoil the party but like um but
i don't mind if other people drink but i
just think it's not
it's not a healthy thing to do and uh so
i didn't start it i love that all right
so you're growing up uh
there you moved to this town of 2000
people and then what do you do
um well i went to school and after
high school which is in germany high
school is like high school plus college
in america
so when i was 19 um i actually had one
year of
civil service which was maybe the most
important thing because
till i was 19 it was 18 until i finished
high school i was extremely set to do
something academic so i was
i had the luck i was really really good
in school i got a lot of scholarships so
and i was really thinking okay
i'm gonna go to university study become
a professor or whatever
um and then i did i had to do one year
of civil service
so you either in germany go to the army
or you go to hospital
and i thought as a libertarian i didn't
really know the word back then but like
i thought that's really a crime that the
government is telling me for
one year of my life what to do so i had
this sort of silent revolution
that i i think it's very bad if i tell
it no but it doesn't matter it's 20
years ago
um so i didn't show up i was always like
going to the doctor
and uh and saying that i'm sick and i
can't go and uh i started actually
speculating on the stock market and then
i did it for friends that i was managing
a bit of money and then
so in this one year i changed from a
very academic sort of
trajectory to a very entrepreneurial one
and then i started studying economics
but i was already set now this was 1999
i need to do my own company this was the
first internet boom
um and i was like okay i need to find an
idea
and then i had this scholarship for for
science
uh and so i had this site tutoring with
two famous guys who were like
biology professors and i asked them okay
hey
what are you doing when you're not
tutoring little christian
um and they told me about an idea which
was super fascinating i understood half
of it
it was practically simply if i'd said
how you switch on and off the human dna
and i was like that sounds so great i
might have found the guys to start my
company with
and i said why don't we do it together
and i don't know why they said yes to a
19 year old turning 20 but we did the
company together it was called ripo
pharma it's now called an island
um and it became really big because
these two guys meet all
credentials to them they had made these
amazing innovation and the company
today i mean i sold very early but the
company today on island is like a
didn't check it lately but like 15 16
billion dollar
company so there was a start in biotech
i skipped uni then
i was never really there ever um and
since then i'm investing uh
founding and investing so i'm somewhat
in between
an entrepreneur and investor and so
when you started that first company and
it started to get big
you sold it at some point what was the
thought process between
uh you know trying to run the company
forever and that being kind of your
legacy versus
selling it and going and doing other
things how did you kind of think through
what you should do
i was always meaning it was never
meaning first of all i was the junior
partner so the two guys were
running it yeah so um i was uh raising
the first funds and
and i was always and this is what still
what i am like i would say something in
between very entrepreneurial
but also like more like an investor who
wants to have a portfolio so i'm always
interested
in new stuff i don't want to do one
company or one thing the whole day the
whole year like
so early on like i was looking left and
right and
what can i build around what else can i
do so it was always
clear that i want to build up a
portfolio
got it that makes a ton of sense and so
today basically
most of the things that you do are under
a period investment group it's
kind of family office slash business how
do you kind of think through that
uh that entity well it's so um it's a
pyron or and people always say a period
was a was a famous uh
mythological horse i think and the pyron
uh it's just the eei um is um
is sort of the the philosophical idea of
the essence
that every every every thing uh has an
essence a core which is immutable and
defines what it is and that's the
pyron in the in in in greek philosophy
i'm super
super geek when it comes to history so
um so our pyramid is
my family office so we don't we have
inner pyramid it's just my own capital
um uh we have two funds which we
span out so to say but i'm still the
sort of the gp and i'm also the the
largest lp in the funds
yeah so we have sort of outside money
in two defined strategies but in our
pyron itself
it's just our own capital and we do
three things we do
biotech which is obviously where um i
started
we do a lot of fintech insurtech
proptech
and crypto which is obviously how we met
and then we also we do the third thing
is deep tech which is anything from
space tag ai
robotics so all the cool stuff
real technological innovation so let's
start with the biotech space
uh you have done an incredible amount
you've got
a thai life sciences uh which has led to
all kinds of innovation in different
companies maybe just start with like
what is your
thesis on biotech or what are the areas
that you're most interested in in that
bucket
a broad question so first of all i think
um
biotech will be the at least one of the
most likely
the best performing asset class
maybe next to bitcoin but like i think
let's say
one of the the best performing asset
classes i think really we're going into
this golden age of biotech
so what tech was and obviously tech will
still do well but like what tech was the
last two decades
i think the next two decades will be
biotech so i'm super excited that
practically
we're going back where we started and
this is why over the last
four or five years uh we've built up
sort of our biotech portfolio which is
at the moment around about 50 of of my
entire
portfolios in biotech um and and it may
cover it it's just if you take over this
is one
symptom of wrong word it's one example
where actually we see that
people um extremely value their health
so i think the same pandemic 20 years
ago
would have led to a different treatment
or treatment i mean
different handling of it so the fact
that we more or less with a broad
majority that people say hey let's do
the lockdown yeah
and now we're going to lock down
discussions but like it's so emotional
in america it's so political
but just like if you see that the fact
that people approve it
although definitely the lockdowns have a
very negative effect on
the economy but also by the way but it's
not on the health of the people
indirectly but people
want the government to take care of
their health i think more than they did
20 30 years ago so the priorities have
shifted yeah so people demand
health and i think politicians are
realizing that and a lot of politicians
i'm speaking to are like well beyond
covet
we want to focus way more on keeping our
our voters healthy actually yeah and
that means that companies biotech
companies which deliver
our product is making people hopefully
healthy yeah that they're going to go up
in value and i think it's a little bit
like the
super macro uh view on it and then
actually
uh also another um another
driver is that if you look at all the
ancillary services you need to start and
run about the company
they all have the prices of them like
gene sequencing whatever
buying a genetic modified mouse yeah so
that all has crashed like partly 99
cheaper 95 cheaper than it used to be so
so
many many factors feeding into that that
i think
as i said biotech is going to be the the
number one asset class over the next
10 20 years
and then within biotech meaning
obviously almost everything in biotech
is interesting because you always help
people
but our view or our main focus is on
longevity um and on mental health
because sort of my
i'm actually always very honest like i'm
doing or i'm
i want to be sure so the two things
or the three things i really want in
life i want to be happy which was always
like very important for me that i
sort of live my life in a way that i'm
happy and i
i think i am i wake up in the morning
life is awesome like i feel
comfortable it doesn't mean every day is
great but like you sort of we have a
basic
sort of happiness feeling so i want to
be happy
then i want to be healthy obviously and
once you help healthy and happy
you want to live at least very long if
not forever
at least i want to live as long till
i say look no more i had enough
christmases i had enough birthdays
yeah so so this is why we focus
practically very egoistically on these
two things on mental health on the one
side
and on on longevity on the other side so
let's start with longevity first because
i think that one is
uh what people are probably most
familiar with out of those two uh
on the longevity side how do you see the
technology landscape
uh kind of evolving and are we talking
about things that are
um kind of uh short-sighted in the sense
of like hey if we just make you
healthier then you can live longer or
are we talking about things that are
much more
long-term like we literally want to make
it so that you can live for
200 years 250-year type stuff
so it's getting there it's getting to
the letter one so i think
as you said first of all obviously you
can always say every biotech
progress which avoids us dying like
every cancer treatment if you don't die
of cancer you're gonna live longer than
average yeah
although by the way it's not i think the
number i just read
was like even if we completely would
eradicate cancer
um the overall life expectancy would
just go up like
three years or something because then
you die of something else when you're
very old yeah
so it's not that easy so what we're
talking about when we talk about
longevity
is really finding the reason why we age
so my personal view is and i know it's a
controversial i don't even understand
why it's controversial because i think
everybody
should think aging sucks yeah um but uh
but aging is not natural we know how
we need you still look here very young
and hot but like
we know how the 20 year old anthony
looks because your dna is
the same on the day you were born and
that you were 20 on a
on a day you're 80. yeah but something
is happening
by the translation of sort of the the
construction plan for anthony
is is sort of changing so why do we get
wrinkles why do we get gray hair so
something is going wrong yeah and
philosophically seen because because
it's happening
since humanity is thinking and
recording memorizing it we ingrained
aging and dying so much in our culture
and our religion
that we deeply deeply think it's natural
but
the same in the medieval ages people
were thinking
that the black death is a punishment of
god and
somewhen and it was really for them it
was miraculously people were dying they
had these
whatever things on the skin and
somewhere they were dying it was okay it
must be a punishment of god and just
like
very later we found out no it's a it's a
bacterium yeah and we can cure it yeah
and the same i think somewhere we're
gonna see and we start actually already
now to understand
why we're aging yeah and we can say it
is a disease
and once we understand why we're aging
we will be able to stop it
slow it down stop it and someone will
even be able to reverse it yeah so
that's natural that's how humans
progress
yeah and uh and this is what we focus on
so really pushing the boundaries
of understanding aging and and hopefully
finding
sort of cures or slowing it down and and
by that you automatically
expand life expectancy much
more than what is now seen to be normal
over the last two years uh or prior to
the last two years i knew nothing about
this stuff
and i started to look more into it when
i heard um i think it was uh david
sinclair maybe
was the guy who basically started
talking about you know aging is a
disease
right and that's a framework that i
think most people don't think of it
through
uh but when you start to really
understand kind of what's happening in
the body
uh one it becomes very fascinating that
like yes it is more likely that this is
a disease than anything
uh and just perhaps that we all get it
but also too is
it feels like we've made pretty far
advancements in understanding
how far have the advancements though
been in how do we actually address it or
how do we
you know take life expectancy from you
know kind of late 70s early 80s to
let's say 150 years like is that
something that's likely to happen
quickly is that something where you know
there's somebody who's born today that
will live to 150
how do you kind of just think through
the progress that's being made again
these are all
hopefully educate the guests i'm making
but i i think somebody's born today
will live have let's say have the
potential to live some hundred years
because also what people underestimate
is
and again by the way but have to say i'm
a super optimist for technology in
general and for progress but like
but i think we're underestimating
um exponential growth in biotech so we
all are used to like if you look at our
iphone
yeah uh meaning what was it like 11
years ago
12 years ago there was no iphone when
was it like it was 10
12 years ago i think it's 67. yeah and
if you then see
how much has changed and how much
progress we had in 10 12 years yeah
so we tend not to see that automatically
in biotech because the
the the the so because because
we we have these sort of phase one phase
two phase three
so which takes a long time so what
people see now actually everything you
or everything the normal person sees
coming out of the biotech industry to
market is actually
technology from 10 years ago so and
what's actually happening
right now is that we see the same
exponential growth
yeah we have seen in a lot of other
technologies we're also seeing in
biotech
but the consumer so to say will really
start
realizing that in maybe five years from
now
but like i firmly believe like in the
next 10 to 20 years
we will see enormous progress in biotech
on all fronts
yeah which a lot of people maybe at the
moment can't grasp so if you think
that's true
if you're like uh 40 years old at the
moment
yeah you your life expectancy today is
let's say
80 for the sake to make it simple so you
have a 40-year
remaining life expectancy so and now
think about it
if you look at other technologies where
you realize what exponential growth is
what in these 40 years four zero
years of exponential growth
can and will happen i think it's really
hard to imagine so
so let's say just now to be easy and
simple and conservative
that we will be able to within the next
20 30 40 years
to push life expectancy 20 years so from
80 ish to 100 but that adds another
20 years of optionality so the way i
look at all of that
is pure optionality i want to have
optionality because i think we're
actually right that uh
at the how is that inflection point
where this all takes off
yeah and my view is if i survive the
next 20 years
then sort of the game is open for
for way longer yeah and this is why
sorry for the long explanation but
if i throw out now i believe i can be
150 200 whatever people say
okay he's crazy but if you see that that
it's not a
it won't there will be not a day where
we wake up in the morning
and you're going to read the headline oh
life expectancy jumped from
80 85 to 150 but it's sort of a gradual
sort of increase and i just need to make
sure
that i'm always still alive when the
next breakthrough
is happening if it makes sense
absolutely and lasting on the longevity
before we move on is just
what do you do personally uh in terms of
kind of positioning yourself for the
highest probability or longest life are
there things that you
eat or drink or or uh you know certain
habits that you have
that uh that you're focused on well i
have a lot
so i i tried because i'm okay this i'm
also very geeky in that so i i
um i take i think like 40 pills a day
like uh
everything like what is not bad like no
but actually
first of all by the way so uh again um
i'm
i'm 42 so what is the main risk
for me for somebody who's around 40.
yeah
it's actually in the next again just
focused on let's make it simple to not
die the next 20 years
so the one is like um not getting a
cardiovascular disease
yeah the second one is not getting
cancer and the third one is not getting
no not have an accident so if you avoid
if you're 40 and if you avoid having
cancer a cardiovascular disease or um
or an accident the likelihood that you
still around when you're 60 is actually
pretty high
so my whole regime is is centered around
risk mitigation so i'm not skiing i'm
really wherever i can i'm not going on a
german autobahn
yeah because driving a car is insanely
risky um
i'm really trying to think through not
doing any stupid risky thing
to avoid the accident second and then
the second is like have a health regime
which is focused on not getting cancer
and not getting a cardiovascular disease
which is a lot but like the main thing
is our outcome is really bad like i can
come back to that i know i'm
party pooper but like alcohol is really
bad
smoking is really bad so by the way it's
these famous 80 20 rules you can do a
lot
but if you sort of focus on let's say
five six core things like no alcohol no
smoking
i'm obsessed with sleep so i think you
have to mean
we we have there is this great book
because i can tell you now in
five minutes what the guy have has put
in a book which is amazing it's called
why we sleep
from from matthew walker and it just
shows you the statistics what's
happening
with your body when you sleep too little
yeah so for example i
try to have the luxury to not wake up
with an alarm clock so i
always try to do emails in the morning
so i can wake up whenever i want so my
body can take the sleep
yeah i need like around about eight
hours by the way there's also no chance
no chance
that you train yourself to sleep less if
anybody thinks that
it's always a disastrous outcome you
have a natural genetic
sleep need and you need to keep it so
sleep and alcohol
um getting your basic nutrition what
david sinclair is actually
um promoting which is very good is an
nmn and nad plus
which is sort of uh i want to say it's a
vitamin because it isn't but it's like a
nutrition
um what you can get um resveratrol is
good fasting is great so i try to do
i don't eat or i don't have any calorie
intake for 16 hours a day so i do
every day forever like since years
intermittent fasting because it's the
way i can
integrate it easy in my life checkup is
super important
yeah a lot of bad things you see
happening like you can
uh if you really would be about to get a
heart attack you can see that a year or
partly two with the right sort of
checkup
cancer whatever so if you get it if you
see it early it's not that bad
so i do a checkup every year like yeah
that may be the main things but i have a
whole
uh list of stuff i think that's a
fantastic
great it's which is by the way one of
the first sort of
longevity drugs meaning by the way this
is obviously i'm not a doctor obviously
uh everybody needs to consult but like
metformin is a diabetes drug
which seems to have a very positive
effect on uh on aging
got it uh and then from a diet
standpoint do you
you said intermittent fasting but when
you do eat do you eat any
specific type of diet um i try to do but
it's i think there is a little bit more
complicated i don't think
it's it's a little bit also how your
body reacts on certain stuff so i don't
mean i do a low carb diet
but because i know i react badly on
carbs yeah
at least on the sort of bad ones bread
pasta whatever
but other people might need it so but in
generally i'm in the
sort of little meat note zero meat but
a lot of fish yeah um a lot of times
mediterranean yeah got it all right
let's switch gears to uh mental health
um i feel like this is uh been thrust
into the
um you know kind of main stage with uh
kovid and the lockdowns and all of that
uh you've got a very specific i think
one view on
mental health in general and kind of how
big of a problem it is but also what
some of the solutions are
just walk me through kind of why you're
so interested in this space
okay one interest i mean it came a
little bit by
i told you like on a one side i was
always interested
for myself completely egoistic in being
happy
and i actually i think or i think i'm
sure i have to attribute it to my
parents so my parents always
gave me i'm i was super relationship
they gave me all the love i needed and
they always
sort of gave me the feeling that i
should be who i want to be like
so there was no but i coming from a very
basic background it was
zero centered around sort of success so
it was just like
sort of be a happy child like do
whatever you want there was zero
pressure to do
x or whatever yeah so but i think so i
always
first of all i was always and i'm happy
but i also was always
interested because somewhere in around
20 i started figuring out
other peoples are actually not always
happy so many
becoming a second to mental health when
you really say depression and sort of
the very
sort of the defined illness but what
always
negatively fascinated me that if you
look at
at humans like while maybe
maybe 15 of of the world population have
really like a clinically diagnosed
mental health issue like depression or
whatever i think they're
very little people who truly would say
that they are happy so i think there is
a huge part in between like who would
say well i'm not depressed but i'm
also not really happy so i was always
interested in that i produced a movie
um which did very well which was called
hector and the search for happiness uh
with uh
some cool people like rosamond pike and
christopher plummer so
there's always this happiness thing and
then i had this one evening
where actually friends were setting me
up a bit because
so i was at a dinner and there was a
very famous neuroscientist who's
actually
um sort of also like sort of the drug
star in germany like
for the public opinion on what's good
what's bad like
and uh and they told him they said oh
you need to loosen up christian a bit
because then he could drink alcohol with
us tonight so they were thinking like
this guy could convince christian to
drink one glass of alcohol
yeah and so they set me next to him and
were like this guy can tell you you're
not gonna die
when he's being echoed i was like look
guys i know i'm not gonna die only by
the way
and the only reason why i'm so strictly
not drinking alcohol now
is because the social pressure is so
high once you start so the good thing is
everybody knows christian is not
drinking so nobody even when i do
business in
china or whatever nobody's bothering me
yeah which is very rare because normally
they
yeah and so so but i started talking to
the guy i can't say the name because
he's always a little bit worried to
what comes next what he promoted and i
was like look i'm super
pragmatic i'm an investor let's go
through um all the drugs out there like
legal and illegal and if you can tell me
there is one drug who has
more upsides than downsides i'm
completely up for it like or let's
think about it and then he pulled up
actually a chart and
for everybody who's watching you need to
watch the charter or google it if you
because it's another colleague of him
here in london who in the meantime
uh is also a good acquaintance professor
david
nutt like n-u-t-t and if you google
david not chart then his famous chart
comes up what he did
he ranked every single drug legal and
illegal
actually how risky it is and without
spoiling the surprise but alcohol comes
out first so in a in an
overall risk assessment um
actually alcohol and this was actually a
little bit the controversial part of his
study but it's a complete
accurate study alcohol is is way is
in an overall risk assessment is is a
little bit more risky than heroin heroin
came second
yeah um and then came crack cocaine
whatever so
so in the chart like you see like very
bad at the beginning
and then at the very end practically no
risk
came all the psychedelics like mbma
magic mushrooms lsd
and this guy that's why i can't say the
name was like christian
don't touch the rest don't even have
alcohol yeah don't touch heroin
obviously don't touch anything of these
bad stuff because you see it's bad
but you should do actually psychedelics
and you should especially do magic
mushrooms and i was like look
you're insane like it's an illegal drug
i don't even drink alcohol although i
saw it in front of me that alcohol is so
so so more badly you can't even rate it
because
magic mushrooms have really like low
risk or practically the only risk of
mushrooms which she told me was like you
can
sort of hurt yourself or have an
accident when you do it
um but i was like look this is no i'm
not gonna do it i stay like
completely sober like like i am but he
was like look i am
he actually did his phd which super
impressed me
with a famous guy called professor
hoffman who was the guy who synthesized
lsd
so he was like let me send you all the
studies this was so well researched in
the 60s and 50s and then
it became purely illegal for for
political
reasons it should have never gotten
illegal um
and you're a biotech guy so you're gonna
understand it let me say i was like okay
i'm always up for new stuff so that's
one of the things in life i think you
need to
by the way and i believe sorry when i'm
jumping now but this is
an integral part of staying healthy
healthy meaning young in your brain we
talked about a lot
um about how staying young young in the
body but we didn't talk about aging of
the brain which is
aging like physical aging but also like
people yeah
age sort of they become complacent
whatever so and i believe in you need to
shock your brain
all the time positively shocked with new
ideas so i was okay bring it on i wanna
i wanna look at new stuff so he sent me
all the stuff i read it
and it was really compelling meaning
again let's say with
magic mushrooms they were legal they
were used
as a medication we had all the studies
in the 60s
and it was a pure political reasons why
they
why they went uh became illegal so it
stick in my mind it took me a year
though so i'm
less adventurous maybe as some might
think so and then
and i also i'm very spiritual i believe
that things are happening
at the right moment in the right moment
in life
and time so one year later i was with my
dearest friends
in the caribbean which is an important
side note because it's a place where
it's legal
and they had real magic mushrooms like i
saw it was organic it was
homegrown so to say and they were like
wanna try
um and i read so much about it i called
my friend the guy
who told me about it it was like shola
and he was like as a doctor i tell you
do it can't be better set in setting and
it was the single most meaningful thing
i've ever done in my whole life
nothing really comes close and i can't
sort of
emphasize how how
yeah important groundbreaking that was
um
why
that's very hard to describe that's
that's one of the
sort of i try but like as a disclaimer
before the problem on a problem though
the beauty is that you go
you go on a completely different
let's say as a discount i just want to
be precise and because i want to be
precisely so complicated
you can't describe psychedelic use
without using religious terms
it's a very spiritual drug they have
been used actually for
thousands of years um in
uh in ceremonial setting actually most
religions actually
including christianity are most likely
based on
psychedelic use so but when i use now a
religious term because religions is one
of the really like
sort of everybody even if somebody would
say he's an atheist
religion is so ingrained in our life
that if i use the word let's for the if
i use the word god or soul
you gonna have an immediate
idea in your mind that it might be
different
from what i try to say so so it's really
a problem of language because our
especially religious terms are so
loaded with history and emotions and
personal belief yeah so
so but ultimately you're going on
another level of
consciousness where in one way or the
other but interestingly
all the descriptions of people who are
doing it are then ultimately similar
again they're trying to
describe if if you've done it you
immediately know what they want to
describe
you you meet sort of you can say the
divine the core of the universe
some people would say they meet
themselves which is one of the very very
healing aspects of psychedelics is that
you
meet yourself and um in a very
positively naked pure form your
call it your soul your inner self your
whatever you know what i mean like and
and uh and this gives you
so much insights you could say this is
like
the positive effects of psychotherapy
within
what what other people would achieve of
10 000 hours of psychotherapy
you achieve in four hours of trip yeah
and that is so valuable it's also it
gives
everybody as it seems what he or she
needs
at this certain moment in time so you
might come out
and have a totally different it's called
the revelation or learning and these are
all also
teachers drugs like again this is what
they were used for
for thousands of years for people to
learn and
and grow as a human being so you might
have it just
a different sort of takeaway because you
might need a different lesson or a
different learning than i might need at
the same time so
also all of my trips they have been
similar and different with the messages
or the learnings they had at
different points over the last years and
they change and
this is the beauty of it what is the
kind of manifestation of this in terms
of where you're putting capital
uh or the companies that you're building
i know you've got a thai i know you uh
compass like
there's kind of a whole bunch of stuff
that's going on how do you think about
where you're actually investing um and
then also what companies you're building
well so so after that trip i had um
i um this was one of the first ideas i
had was like oh my god
this needs to be legal again because
this is i mean i realized if it had
such a profound positive experience on
me
as a happy person yeah and again it
made my life tremendously
even more happy yeah but already
starting at a decent sort of um
level of happiness i completely
understood what i had read before purely
on paper
that it why it works for people who have
depression anxiety
addiction or any form of of mental
health issue
so so i was like okay that needs to be
legal again and then i
um i was actually looking around because
i was convinced somebody needs to work
on that because these are so powerful
substances and then nobody did
i mean not in this millennia so to say
yeah because it was completely again
this is one of the saddest part of
politics that we were
uh that these substances sort of were
shut down or were taken taken away um
and then i was actually i was looking
around and uh
i can tell the story because you know
the other guy i think but it is one of
the
stories i always use because because
again i'm personally very spiritual and
i think
things happen at the same time what
happened is i had one later i mean for
two years i was looking around and like
talking to scientists but
this was all again now everybody talks
about psychedelics and
you have books about it and people are
open about it
but like it was really like this was a
fringe science and scientists were
there so it's always very important yeah
i want to make clear because i mean it's
obvious but i did not invent
psychedelics like i'm
standing on the shoulders of giants
there's a cool people who are not around
anymore like
shulgin or hoffman or whatever but they
are still also very
amazing people from from back then
around like
uh like rick dublin who's running maps
and whatever so i tried to get in touch
with these people with scientists
whatever
and then i um and it's a big shout out
to him because uh and we have
he's also a sheldon of a thai so i was
in new york after i
came did not do in america so i came
from uh uh
right after christmas i had one of the
best trips trips literally trips of my
life
i was in new york and on this trip one
of the message was
christian you should talk about it more
openly because it's so
positive and and so it's you shouldn't
be afraid because
the first two years i was not like now
on a podcast like
i was telling my parents i was telling
like friends yeah but i was very holding
back yeah because
a lot of people said don't talk about it
meaning you're in finance like you're
you're an investor like you i have a lot
of politicians as friends
like don't talk about magic mushrooms um
and um
so and on this one trip which was a very
defining one
the message actually of the trip was do
talk about it
so i went to new york and i met mike
novogratz
and he was sort of the first person to
work on my
my mission because mike was like you
know like how he is hey what you up to
and i was like well actually i just did
an amazing magic mushroom trip and i
told mike the same what i told you for
two hours like how amazing it is
and um and like many other people he was
like well that's interesting
i had done it in my youth like it's a
college drug maybe in america
but i haven't done it and he had not
talked about it for 20 years or whatever
so the next day the phone is my phone is
ringing it's mike and he was like
christian you can't believe it
this is such a rare or weird coincidence
you told me
about magic mushrooms yesterday for the
first time in 20 years
and one day later he said my sister
called me
she's on bali with a crazy couple from
london
who are working on bringing magic
mushrooms back as a depression treatment
and she called mike and said from all
people i know you might be crazy enough
yeah to finance these guys and mike was
like well my friend christian
is in london and might be even a bit
crazier yeah
so and this is how i met george
goldsmith and and his wife
uh katya um who were thinking the same
they were
comp it's the company compass and uh
compass wasn't even existing they were
thinking about starting it
and needed a seed investor but back then
most of the people said again
don't touch that can't put money and
most of the venture fund said who
we don't know yeah by the way although
everything we do at compass in a tie is
completely legal because we're running
clinical trials we're not
yeah um anyway so i met george and katya
amazing human beings and after 15
minutes i was like you know what
uh i'm in yeah i'm giving you the money
you need um
to start compass and uh i called mike
uh because obviously he sort of made the
intro and said you want to be on board
and then i also called my friend peter
thiel
because he's also interested in this
crazy kind of stuff
um here we are so that was the
foundation of compass which was the
first
for-profit psychedelic company again in
this millennia
and so how does a thai fit in like a
thai is almost like a holding company
that holds
uh equity in compass and a number of
other companies
so right after we started compass
compass was always focused on
uh let me precise the active ingredient
in magic mushrooms and the artificial
synthetic version which is called
psilocybin
and the more than i dived into it this
was now 2017.
the more i dived into it i realized well
there are more psychedelic drugs and by
the way the brain is also
a very complex uh organ so
uh there is there will never be a one
drug fits all there will not even be
another proponents of psychedelic drugs
will solve everything i think
psychedelic drugs as a
sort of a universe of drugs are an
extremely important part of the tool set
but also other drugs we still have like
ssris
yeah psychotherapy whatever it's it's
what i think it's like it's you have to
give a doctor who knows the patient the
tool set and then he can pick but
so i realized there are more of these
psychedelics there is dmt which people
know because it's the
active ingredient of ayahuasca um there
is ibogaine which is the only known
compound or only known drug we know
which is completely
uh or has the potential to completely
eradicate addiction
yeah so if it's used actually in mexico
already in clinics to get people off
even heroin and opioids
which is one of the strongest forms of
religion there is uh there are new
versions of ketamine who can be very
um supportive or very helpful against
depression so there are so many
so compass wanted to focus on um on um
on cybin so i was like okay but i
i want to work on all the again what i
told you before i always want to have a
portfolio
so i started a thai as a platform
where we built up a very strong team
it's more than a holding
because what i realized is encompass is
a little bit the exception because they
already
george came out of the uh of the
sort of business side he knew how to run
and fundraise and whatever
so but most of the people who actually
scientists who were working with
these trucks again they never stopped
they were just like very fringe they
were not commercial they didn't know how
to raise money they and it's by the way
it's even a different talent to
sort of know everything about a truck
how it works and then to
structure a clinical trial yeah uh
whatever so so a tie is way more than a
holding we have
a strong single trial team yeah we have
up to the obviously a strong finance
team fundraising we raised more than
um 200 million over the last two years
um and and we started actually
partnering
with a lot of these scientists yeah
there is a
a great colleague deborah mash she's
working on
ibogaine since more than 20 i think 30
years yeah she's mississippi
what rick dublin is for mdma deborah is
for ibogaine so we partnered with
deborah
yeah and now have a a 50 50 uh
joint venture where we bring ibogaine
back as a therapy for
for or against addiction yeah so we
started onboarding
all of these drugs on our thai platform
yeah and have now more than 12
new mental health drugs in the pipeline
in various stages of
clinical trials got it and so when you
think about kind of where
the psychedelic space is going is this
something where
uh we'll continue to see um kind of
acceptance in the medicinal space and
and uh it'll be much more heavily
regulated it'll be for mental health and
other type of
health uh you know issues or do you
think that we'll eventually see
kind of recreational type legislation
and uh really anyone in the united
states will be able to
go to a store they can buy marijuana
they could buy psychedelics they could
buy alcohol
they'll kind of just have you know
really free choice across a lot of these
different uh
items i mean i
hope but i also don't um
i also see the future in the medical
field
for a very simple reason it's not
mariana it's not cannabis
it's it's it's waste all these
psychedelics here
starting from magic mushrooms they are
way stronger
way more potent which is the beauty of
them
but they were never recreational drugs
never
so while mariana was always used either
as a sort of these sort of let's say a
creational party side
if you look and i'm very very also
trying to understand and learn more
always about the history of psychedelics
they were always used in a religious
ceremonial setting
with a guide call it shaman call it
priest
and a disciple yeah they were never used
at home for like just
partying yeah but it's very important
because they're extremely
strong drugs and part of the upside
and also if you look at if you look at
patients
and that's what we focused on part of
the healing process
is also the interaction with the
therapist so this is not a
a smarty drug you pop at home and then
the disease miraculously goes away
yeah so big part of the healing is that
you do the trip
together with your therapist and by the
way you might have a
bad trip i don't like the word because
bad trips can also be incredibly healing
but but they can be very very
challenging so i like the word
challenging trip
yeah so and then especially then and by
the way especially when trauma is coming
up within trauma
is is a is a is a root uh
for a lot of mental health issues yeah
then even more you need somebody
going through this process with you and
literally guiding you through the trip
so and this is why
i'm extremely um focused on and i hope
this stays
a very strictly medical truck because
also
me that doesn't mean by the way you and
i and whoever wants
can grow mushroom at home yeah i'm very
pro
and these are to be precise and very pro
decriminalization so you have
practically
three popcorns you have the medical
pocket
definitely then you have the should it
be legal and sold
everywhere definitely not yeah and then
you have sort of these
decrim like should people who grow it
themselves who know what they're doing
yeah who maybe do it with a very
spiritual background that should be
totally fine
yeah and a lot of countries by the way
like the netherlands portugal
parts of the us now handle it like that
yeah but it should not be sold lightly
yeah on the street ever or like even not
like cannabis in nice shops to people
who don't know
um and understand the power of it
without a guide
yeah uh and that's also sorry when i
talk about it because that's really like
the essence of
what we want to do with the tie and i
also want to make clear i had the
super luck as i said 10 times but like i
came from a very happy place um
i had the right people around me so i
did have great
guides yeah um in in my first and in the
following trip so
everything was right i had also the
money to go to the caribbean
to be at a nice place so but ultimately
a thai and compass
we're doing that stuff because there are
hundreds of millions of people
out there who have a really a mental
health
issue yeah there are more than more than
300 million people
who suffer from depression and most
likely that it's just the official
number the inofficial number because
depression and all of that is still a
stigma people don't talk about it
so most likely the real number is even
bigger yeah you have hundreds of million
who suffer from addiction
whatever so and i really want to make
clear yeah again
everybody can have a great trip at
birmingham whatever yeah but like
we've we want to make sure that these
people who really need it and by the way
these are not the people who would go to
burning man
yeah these are the people who need a
doctor because they are in a
in a bad place to start and we want to
make sure that these people
have access to these amazing powerful
drugs
yeah and so when you think about
kind of this biotech bucket is that
literally one-third of kind of your
focus fintech's one-third deep text
one-third or is
biotech it sounds like it's 50 of your
kind of investments but what about like
from a share standpoint do you spend 50
of your time thinking about biotech
versus the other buckets or is there a
difference between the amount of capital
that you've deployed versus
uh kind of how you spend your time
thinking it's very hard to say because
my
days and are changing whatever is at the
moment sort of i i would say
where my companies need me so i'm
extremely
um one of our our main
focus i would say by the way every
investor would say he or she is hands-on
yeah but but i think we really hands-on
as an investor
mainly because i'm coming my heart i'm
an entrepreneur so as i said i
i think i do certain things really well
which an entrepreneur should do well
like all the
macro picture like fundraising
strategy vision but i'm not a good
operator so i
shouldn't run a business so this is what
i realized right so so i'm not doing it
yeah this way even for a tie i founded a
time myself but i teamed up
with great guys florian srini who
running the day-to-day business
and i'm doing that super well so um but
like
because i'm in my heart i'm an
entrepreneur i'm like extremely hands-on
and trying to support my portfolio
companies wherever i can
with whatever they need so so this
fluctuates so sometimes this company
needs me sometimes there so
so it's not there is no real typical
christian day
they're all a little bit different um
and then there's interestingly by the
way there is a lot of um
there is a lot of overlap or synergy so
i have to say
so there are there would be two people i
credit
with or two to one person and one
event like which i credit with
understanding bitcoin
three people mike novogratz told me
first and i did not listen
which was maybe one of the biggest
mistakes i listened when he called me
for mushrooms
so but i did not listen early enough
when he called me
and he told me like this was 2012. you
need to buy bitcoin and i was like damn
it
so then um actually mike introduced me
to brandon bloomer
who then again gave me the whole pitch
on bitcoin
and the u.s and then i thought about
exactly what brenton told me some weeks
later on a mushroom trip
and then i was like now i get it um so
so i think so it's a fun example like
that there is a lot of sort of indirect
synergies you learn
and ultimately i think for an investor
the important thing is you need to stay
open like you need to yeah you need to
want to learn
stuff and i i'm a little bit like a
like a puppy you throw a ball in the air
and i'm like oh my god this is the
nicest ball i've
ever seen yeah so um so like
right before we had uh our call i spoke
to an anthropologist
about where humans come from which i
want to
learn more about because we're also
investing start investing a lot in
in brain computer interface stuff yeah
which ultimately
could change what we are as a human and
i think if you want to deal with that
stuff you should
understand what makes us human and how
can we preserve that
in in technology anyway i i think there
there is a bigger i know it sounds like
okay he's doing biologic he's doing
crypto he's doing deep tech
but there is for me sort of uh um
sort of um you invest
the exact same way that i think uh is
um the absolute best way to invest right
and uh people will think because we're
talking on here that uh i'm just saying
this but they've
if you've listened to the podcast before
people will have heard me say
i basically think of the intersection of
two ideas as
the absolute best place to invest one is
things that are on the fringes of
society but will become
mainstream in the future right so if you
kind of think of uh they are the most
asymmetric
type of opportunities because you're
basically
making a bet on a space or a company
before
everyone else thinks that that is a
thing and when it goes from a contrarian
idea to a consensus idea
there's incredible upside to be captured
and that's where you get the asymmetry
but the second thing also is uh you
invest along
very long time horizons right you're not
day trading stocks you're not kind of
doing a lot of that stuff you are
looking at things that
are going to take you know years if not
decades to
kind of come to fruition and so what
that allows for is a very long period of
time for the
uh capital and uh to compound because of
innovation
and so to me it's all tied together
because it's basically you're looking at
you know society if you will you're
going to the fringes and you're saying
what are the things that today are
accepted at the fringes but not yet at
the mainstream
and how do i basically put stakes in the
ground and the things i believe in there
and then as they kind of get pulled into
the mainstream they become consensus
ideas
obviously they will accrue tons of tons
of value is that fair
perfect summary and i would add i would
add one more important point
i just invest in companies and people
and ideas which somehow excite me
because i don't need to do it i'm not
running a fund
i i have enough that i could stop i
don't want to stop i really i always
would describe it
everything i'm doing is my constant
hobby that's the only reason i can
because i in in work terms i think i
work a lot
yeah but i don't it doesn't feel like
work it feels super exciting because i'm
i would do exactly the same if you would
say i give you four more weeks i was
like well then that's what i'm doing
because i love it yeah
so and one of the things i love and by
the way it's always important
if i come back to self-exploration of
psychedelics that doesn't mean this is
the way to do it because
i think one of the most important things
with psychedelics was and i had that
already before with meditation
and there are other techniques you need
to know what you want as a human being
yeah but i want that that's what
excites me i want to always see new
stuff and i want to invest
in things and companies and ideas and
human beings
who shape the world i hopefully gonna
live in for a very long time
yeah so i want to contribute a little
bit to the world
which yeah which i will be a consumer so
to say
hopefully as i said for for a very long
time
i love it let's talk about bitcoin uh
before i let you go
uh you described a little bit about how
you kind of came across bitcoin what's
your view on it today
um how do you think about it within your
portfolio did you just go buy a bunch of
bitcoin and you're
sitting on it um are there other things
that you're doing in the space just talk
to me kind of about your philosophy and
how you're gaining
uh kind of exposure uh to that asset and
industry
well i'm not trading yeah um i'm as i'm
not trading in anything like so i'm not
uh that's just not you can't do both um
i have a long-term view and i'm
preaching i think to the super converted
like you and
your your viewers but it's i think it's
so simple if you look at the
um edward politicians by the way on both
sides of the spectrum so
both left-wing and right-wing
politicians in europe in
in america everywhere they have they are
actually they are hooked on they are
like opioid that they like they are
addicted to money printing and i think
there is no good outcome
and you can't come off i think it's a
very strong
structural addiction yeah which i
don't think they will overcome i don't
also think it's going to be completely
blowing in our face
but i think that fiat currencies will
gradually but very strongly evaluate
over the next
and and it has already started but i
think the last 10 years
were just a tiny bit of start in what
we're gonna see in the devaluation of
fiat currencies
uh and they're all doing the same so you
don't have an escape that you say oh i
go to this currency or that one
it's a global phenomenon yeah because by
the way meaning
philosophically or observable it's
because also we're living in a
people don't want to suffer yeah uh you
can say this is good but like if i think
about and i come back to fiat currency a
second
when i had my when i lived through the
first
real crisis in crisis i mean the
economic crisis
this was like the 2000 crash and then
2001
when uh the two planes or whatever it
flew in a twin tower yeah
that was a real recession yeah and it
was
similar than corbett because it was not
my fault yeah i was sitting there as a
small entrepreneur
yeah there was a global recession but
back then nobody would have said
well terrorists flew in the twin tower
it's not the fault of
uh companies tech stars we're going to
help you and throw money at you no
back then most of the companies went
bankrupt
and it was healthy by the way i i'm very
skeptical that we
pumping so much money in it yeah and and
then even in 2008 in the crisis
yeah meaning again was lehman my fault
yeah no but i had to go through it
stops i owned were going down companies
had a hard time and
nobody was helping because that's
normally how
economic life was seen you go through
cycles and normally cycles are always an
external shock it's never you
who sort of is responsible anyway and
somehow we switch but this is also a
little bit the
sort of the tight guys is that we don't
want to suffer
suddenly yes covet is bad and kobet is
an external shock but
it's just another external shock and we
could just have said look let's use that
to
sort of let company go bankrupt let
things go
the weak ones i mean it's darwinian
theory but we didn't we said hey no we
don't want to suffer
people shouldn't lose their job let's
throw money on it yeah
and i think they can't stop so people
will always now say hey there is a way
easier way than suffering why don't we
just print money yeah so that's going to
be and there will always be problems
after kobet there will be another
problem another problem
anyway having said that i think we're
going into this 10
20 years cycle of fiat currency
devaluation
which by the way means any solid asset
will go up yeah so
so this is why tech is going up biotech
is going up and
there will be obviously within that mega
cycle there will be
ups and downs but like and bitcoin is
the sort of
synonym for stability or for the
opposite
yeah for integrity yeah for
politicians not being able to meddle
with it so i think
among that is that biotech i think is
one tech
fintech attacker and bitcoin yeah are
sort of the core pillars of uh of my
asset location
do you do any real estate investing a
tiny bit
i tell you i do think there will
interest rates might go up so i'm i i do
really say but not on a large scale and
i'm
i think what we could see which i think
would be a little bit of in that mega
cycle of
of currency evaluation it doesn't mean
that everything is going up like a
straight line so and i
so what my view is my macro few is that
next year
gonna be one of the craziest positive
years of our lives because
i think they're pumping money in the
market as long as cobit is there
and in the moment kovit is over people
will spend like hell
so my my fun quote is like in the
medieval ages there were like
orgies for years straight after the
black death yeah
so and in a certain way we're gonna
bring the orgies on like we're gonna go
on holidays we're gonna go
on concerts like people will spend as
there if there is no tomorrow
my few so we're gonna see an
overshooting economy
and that could for the first time since
10 years or whatever lead to
uh inflation yeah because so far despite
which is interesting despite the money
printing
we didn't see consumer price inflation
we saw asset price inflation already
yeah but if if consumer price inflation
comes which i think could come at least
for a period
yeah then they need to take interest
rates a little bit up and that could be
extremely
sort of negative for the short term for
real estate even for tech by the way
because a lot of the tech valuations are
sort of kind of packed to the super low
um
super low zero interest rate environment
absolutely uh before i get into the
rapid fire questions to uh to wrap this
up
what's the most contrarian idea you have
right now like what's the thing that you
believe
and if you say it other people will be
shocked that you believe it
isn't that the famous peter thiel
question he
he i think uh likes what you
ask or like what you believe that other
people disagree with like what's the
secret that you know that other people
don't know i
i'm asking more about like what is the
thing that you believe that other people
will be surprised that you believe
that's a good question finally we talked
about all the controversial stuff which
is suddenly not controversial anymore
about psychedelics and longevity
whatever
um to me it's more it's more something
that violates
uh how you how people perceive you right
so like
let's say for example somebody who uh is
really religious
right all of a sudden them saying i
actually don't believe in god that would
surprise people about that person
and so what is the thing that um based
on either the work you do
uh the lifestyle you live the uh the
person that you are
that maybe you have a belief that's
counter to what people would expect it
to be
a good question i'm meaning i told you
many i think but it's not counter
because i'm personally actually very
spiritual yeah so
but that's everybody knows that so um
nothing comes i'm always pretty
open with what i believe so it's not i
would say
honestly if like i think if i had
something i really believe in
you would already know because one of
the things is no but one of the things
was always like
i had this big luck that i had success
early on
and i was like i don't need to please
anybody i hopefully people like me i
actually want to be liked
hi this is why i couldn't go in politics
like i i hope people
who like me like but like but i don't
need to like i
so i always thought like be open of and
that's what and actually it served me so
well i mean you always have then one or
two
negative experiences where people abuse
that openness
but in general again take the magic
mushroom thing if i wouldn't have been
open
again in a time where it was not sort of
convenient to be open about magic
mushrooms
uh i we wouldn't sit here like i
wouldn't have compounds i wouldn't have
a tie
yeah so being open about what i think
um um actually
um actually served me well
so there is nothing hidden i would say i
love that answer
uh i always ask everyone the same two
questions and you'll get to ask me one
at the end the first is what's the most
important book that you've ever read
think and grow rich by far ah why that
one that's one of my three
because it made me to a certain extent i
i i really want to say that strongly i
went
in i really still know it i went in a
bookshop
in munich when i was 14 years
old and there was again i believe in
that stuff so
um there was just like these i think in
english you call it epiphany
yeah um so i go into this bookshop and
there was these um which is not
i think it's not around anymore it was a
very famous one
for the germans listening uh in munich
and then um and i went in and there was
this
massive wall of books all think and grow
rich
and i was like as a 14 year old oh my
god this is
this is it like this is was literally
like
a religious epiphany so i bought the
book and i think it's a beautiful
description
uh for the germans the title is a little
bit uh because in germany we don't like
to talk about money so much uh it's a
little bit of a different culture like
in america it's a very american book
it made me actually very american i
think for a german guy
german friends over that christian is
very very americanized in his thinking
and this is due to this book
yeah and i think though it's so timeless
and i read it maybe 30 times yeah
because i think it's really like it's a
it it works yeah and then later on i
read
more books again more on the spiritual
side respect like law of attraction
which though are the same sort of
takeaways
in different wording yeah so i always
think for the ones who don't want to go
too sort of spiritual crazy at the
beginning like this is a beautiful
easy to serve timeless wisdom
so yeah i i always tell people three
books that i read when i was
20 21 years old uh rich dad poor dad uh
thinking grow rich
and um uh what is the other one um
oh man i'm gonna blink on it no uh
think and grow rich it's it'll come to
me
napoleon hill uh
there is another guy murphy has
similarities all the same age all
the same out of the same time which is
rich is made in babylon that's what it
is
which one the richest man in babylon
okay yeah yeah yeah
those three those three books it's all
the same messaging yes and it works by
the way finally you meet and again
not a lot of people want to talk about
it because it's either they think oh
this is too simple
to sort of do sort of say my success is
based on that or
in germany you would say you don't want
to admit that you read a book and were
fascinated by it when you were 14 which
is called think and grow rich
but but it is like i think everybody if
you think about how messed up
our education system is um
yeah every child should read it this if
i think we would do the world
um uh an enormous uh enormous
favor what about uh second question
which is more fun
aliens are you a believer or a
non-believer oh that's i mean i
definitely believe that they are aliens
um so i mean statistically everything
this must be
this is like yeah um
the question is are they sort of we need
all these sub questions
like are they still there are they
already extinct
can they come to us if they hear that so
but i think yes many i think there are
aliens the question is i don't know if
we gonna make contact
um yeah but i definitely think they are
all right
do you think that we've already made
contact
i think yes but you mean now like in our
lifetime like we
as us our generation or us as humans
humans yes
i actually uh another um actually
psychedelics
are so amazing because you meet so many
amazing people i just had by the way
another thing which is maybe not i don't
wanna
jump now from aliens to that because
he's not talking about aliens but what
goes in that direction is i think
we what what i'm thinking a lot and
which is my sort of
reading list for for the holidays is um
we know so little still where we come
from
yeah and so i had this fascinating
zoom chat um a week ago with graham
hancock
do you know graham hancock yeah amazing
guy meaning his books i started reading
some of them have the whole reading list
and so i think there is
i think we shouldn't not exclude the
alien question the same like
maybe there were high cultures 20 000
years ago which completely got lost
maybe i think we're too stiff
in even in science i think people and
that's what actually is worrying me a
bit you have on the one side you have
you have actually the entrepreneurs who
like and which i think is the right way
to go is like
sort of the sky's the limit and why not
think about that and why not think about
that
but somehow society is sort of very
conformistic
so so so maybe maybe that's a point
people always think
um um i'm gay i'm liberal
but like i'm i'm not so sure if
the the left if if there is the left
is going in the right direction and this
is saying like
with precaution like because we too
conformistic
actually they think they are colorful
but like we sort of
narrowing down too much and thoughts
which are not allowed to be thought and
there should be no
thought we should not we should not be
allowed to be thought we should be way
more open to
to thinking okay why not is this the
right thing you know what i mean like i
think we're
just becoming a little bit con is this
this whole new generation
this pull i hate political correctness i
think it's so wrong why should we
i can decide if somebody is offending me
i turn around and go away
but nobody can offend me like everybody
can say anything like we shouldn't be
like so snowflakey that's maybe what
if to come back to aquarium people might
not think about me but i think we should
be way more
and and we completely losing especially
in politics the
the power of debate yeah we cannot sort
of
the the whole safe space idea is is
completely
alien to me because we yeah doesn't mean
people need to be safe but like say so
you need to discuss things you can't
shut down discussions especially when
they're unpleasant
yeah then we need to have them and then
we need to think about it again we need
to shock our brain with new things all
the time
and not being conformistic all the way
i could not agree more i think that that
is one of the the craziest parts of the
world that we live in today is that
there are certain things that we can't
talk about
and uh one of my favorite lines is uh is
from joe rogan he basically says
uh you know look once an idea goes from
um you know being able to be discussed
to not
we've now transformed into a religion
right
you literally get you you enter into
religions uh kind of uh field
uh all right that is a good good point
because that's
the fine line i said so often because
it's important for my life that i'm
spiritual
but organized religion always turned bad
most
in most of the cases and by the way
that's the
sad part if you look at most religions
were actually based on psychedelics for
everybody's viewing read a book and you
should i told you before they should get
him on the podcast
because that's a whole different topic
like brian murresco he wrote the
immortality key about the
origins of religions based on
psychedelics but what happened so all
religions were based on psychedelics
or mostly most of them yeah including
most likely christianity
at the beginning they were very
inclusive and spiritual but then when
they
turned into an organization people were
actually saying hey let's
exclude the the thinkers the new ideas
because you can't run
an organization with with people
speaking to god every day
so and then every religion if you look
at christianity
islam whatever they went through a phase
where they burned the heretics
yeah but the heretics were the ones who
normally if you look back now
they were the spiritual ones they were
the ones who took psychedelics who were
like so
and we're going through like a new era
where we start burning the heretics
and we're sort of an originally good
idea
sort of the liberal laugh which was
great they fought for many things which
are
important for me personally i don't i
wouldn't be like to be gay in the 50s so
it was extremely valuable but then
somewhere it starts to become as you say
out of something humanitarian out of
something good it starts becoming a
religion
and then a religion starts burning the
heretics and that's
actually actually almost burning your
own
origins yeah and it's very sad
absolutely
you could ask me one question to wrap
this up what do you got for me
what's the most interesting the other
question around because i'm always
interested
in new technologies or new ideas what's
the craziest
contrarian idea you have seen or in your
podcast or in your discussions where i
should look at
i i don't know if it's necessarily crazy
crazier contrarian i think the space
that um is going to be
much better than uh people expect
uh you know obviously there's bitcoin i
think i think including me everyone is
underestimating how big this thing will
get
but we'll see but there's a lot of talk
about kind of
uh brain computer interfaces so how do i
take something and i put it in my brain
i think a lot of uh of interesting
things are going to come out of the idea
of how do i tell my
brain what or how does my brain tell
computers what to do and what i mean by
that
is um you know i recently invested in a
company
called atom limbs that basically uh
they've got prosthetics
uh so let's say a prosthetic arm and
it's connected so that when i
think i can literally move the fingers i
can pick things up i can do things
and it operates just like a regular arm
would uh and it's being controlled by my
brain
right and so when you start to to think
about uh
the brain is a two-directional uh
you know computer basically and so yes
we can definitely augment it we can put
things into the brain we can do all
kinds of great stuff
uh everything from just eating healthier
not drinking lots of alcohol
you know kind of natural type stuff to
literally augmenting it with technology
but also i think about
this idea of connecting
your brain to computers and having your
brain somehow
very quickly tell the computers what to
do i don't quite yet know all the
different ways that that'll be applied
but that to me feels like a big space
that no one's talking about
i actually think that's going to be
something like an iphone is today which
is going to be applied to everything
because what
we're interacting already we're actually
interacting in a very archaic way with
our phone with
typing which is very archaic so they're
trying to upgrade it to uh
to um to language theory whatever but
the natural thing is we'll be just
thinking yeah and i think there is no
meaning i give it 10 years maybe 15
and we i saw another comedy i'm gonna
bring it on like
someone next year when it's out of sales
but like they believe and it's more than
belief because they have the basic
technology for it
in 10 15 years we can do telepathy not
because it's magic but because
if you already exactly what you say if
you already can now tell your arm what
to do
if or a prosthetic arm yeah so that is
your brain thinking and sending a
message yeah the next step is that your
brain will be able to interact with your
computer
that you can dictate an email by
thinking of it but if that happens i can
equally send you a message to you from
brain to brain and that
that and this is what i said before
that's why i'm so interested in
sort of the origins of humanity because
this will
ultimately change what we now
think is human so we need to go to the
very
core what really defines of being human
and then preserve
that while we might leave behind things
which we think now is human but maybe
in 20 years is not anymore could not
agree more
where can we send people to find out uh
more about all the things you're working
on or find you on the internet
um i actually started posting a lot on
linkedin because i think meaning i like
twitter as well
twitter is sometimes a little bit
negative so
i i think linkedin is more it's more
friendly that's another thing i don't
know why people are so negative to each
other
especially on twitter two days i think
not good for your brain meaning i'm
using it
i'm posting stuff if i wanna say
something announce something but i i
think it's like
always when i start using it i get sad
and then i let it go
like because i don't want to be sad um
so
um yeah linkedin i think is the best
that's fair man listen thank you so much
for doing this
you are amazing i love to talk about
what excites me so
um thank you very much was awesome